bien avec eux tout est conçu pour suite
et des bagarres entre banques or donc ce
débat il est je pense que là il
semblerait même qu'un point dans
l'opinion mais monsieur jacob et madame
le pen je pense que là ils perdent
autant de points cécile nos confrères de
l'opinion regarder un peu de près le
hashtag pas de vagues
il ya eu je reprends leurs chiffres cent
mille repris 24 mai les metteurs en
quelques jours face à vraiment c'est un
problème
écoutez moi je connais des gens que je
connais dans mon entourage le raconte un
énorme problème de violons ça dans ma
famille un élève qui est arrivé dans un
collège à tour avec un couteau une élève
de 15 ans imaginez un peu donc il ya un
problème massif qui date depuis des
années le problème c'est qu'il a par
personne a trouvé la martingale on a
laissé aussi ce faire on a aussi
désarmer les profs parce que ce qu'ils
me racontent qu'ils sont à ce titre par
exemple ils sont c'est pas si facile que
ça de mettre un enfant coin par exemple
vous se voir reprocher si la directrice
est pas d'accord
et comme c'est à la limite certains
peuvent considérer que c'est une
humiliation pour un élève et ben c'est
pas toujours si simple
donc voilà il ya plein de plein de il ya
une quête une kamikaze la directrice se
donner la consigne ne fait pas faire des
lignes des enfants c'est une punition
qui équivalent à qui et pas assez
valorisant donc on se retrouve
effectivement et des situations aussi on
a un peu désarçonnés on les a bernés les
parents désarmés et au sida l'an passé
des cas où plus de la violence entre la
décade dont je vous parle effectivement
dans le cas du couteau le père est sdf
et dans l'auto de cas qu'on reconnaît le
père est dealer donc effectivement les
instituteurs les profs il s'entoure d'un
auteur et terriblement démunis il
faudrait un système très ferme face à
ces face à situations d'enfants qui sont
qui sont pas du tout éduqué chez eux
enfin vraiment je vous donne la parole
tout de suite à tous les deux matchs
très courts gars passe pour entrer un
peu vraiment dans le dans le sujet ce
tableau c'est notre sondage aux docks ça
demain
dans le figaro il montre que toutes les
sanctions et mesures de fermeté prévus
sont plébiscités alors ça va de la vidéo
la mise en place de l'ess surveillance
vidéo aux abords des établissements et
même au sein des établissements jusqu'à
la mise en place d'agents de sécurité à
ce propos jean michel blanquer air
toujours en a parlé ce matin il n'exclut
pas l'idée même que ça peut être fait à
titre d'expérimentation pour le moment
de mettre des policiers dans les
établissements on écoute ce gouvernement
prend de manière très sérieuse la
question de la sécurité à bras le corps
appliquée à tous les domaines dans le
domaine de l'éducation ça signifie une
coopération des fortes entre christophe
gasca mère et moi alors je n'ai pas très
bien compris il y aura des policiers où
il peut y avoir des policiers à
l'intérieur des établissements
il peut à titre expérimental nous avons
commencé nous avons commencé à le faire
ça va trop loin des policiers dans les
lycées et les collèges
oui moi je suis prête à temps non mais
je suis pas d'accord parce que
finalement on recourt toujours des
solutions répressives
alors que c'est une question de société
je vous rejoins c'est à dire que la
violence scolaire c'est une résultante
de la violence sociale donc la violence
scolaire c'est presqu'un propres je me
souviens qu'il ya quelques années en f1
un documentaire sur un lycée en banlieue
et on voyait bien que c'était aussi le
dernier endroit de socialisation dans le
quartier c'est à dire que les gens qui
étaient au chômage
les gens qui étaient seules ou une
famille monoparentale
on se rencontrait à la sortie du bahut à
la sortie de l'établissement scolaire et
mais c'est là aussi que la violence des
bouchers parce que les banques pénétrer
parce que parce que les non scolarisés
pénètre dans l'établissement est ce qu
était et c'est donc ce qui se passe à
l'école c'est la résultante d'un prime
de violence et de délinquance et de
manque d'autorité de
de manque de sanctions et de manque de
conscience pour rejoindre le terme que
vous enviez les août à l'heure de la
société française
donc il faut attaquer le phénomène
beaucoup plus en amont est donc là on
est juste à les garder il faut bien
faire quelque chose les situations on
est bien sûr mon recours toujours des
solutions répressives au lieu de
remonter un peu plus haut en dix ans les
noms il faut donner il faut donner des
cours de sens civique d'éducation de
morale à l'école pour pour donner le
fasse je déteste cette expression vivre
ensemble mais mais le goût de de vivre
et le respect des autres
oui peut-être mais c'est jamais trop
tard si on laisse dériver les choses
comme ça j scolaire on a donc c'est
l'éducation et la version les bricoles
aussi un alors qu'il faut bien admettre
que l'enseignant on sent tout
responsabiliser les parents aussi les
enseignants ont une part de
responsabilité parce que d'une certaine
façon et bien ils se sont laisser
marcher sur les pieds
je sais que c'est aujourd'hui c'est
quasiment peine perdue il ya 10 15 ans
ou 20 ans on horizon trop laissé faire
et le laisser faire
vous connaissez bien rare mais ça vous
parle l'idée de mettre un petit peu
d'autorité dans tout ça et d'uniformes
alors d'abord sur l'architecte pas de
vagues concernant monsieur blanc caire
il faut quand même rappeler qu'ils
étaient et recteurs et directeurs
d'administration centrale et donc une
partie des critiques qui lui sont portés
sont légitimes au sens où pendant
longtemps il a été de ceux qui étaient
au coeur du système pour éviter que eux
justement qui est pas de vagues
non mais c'est vrai donc bon maintenant
il se trouve devant un fait accompli je
suis bien d'accord c'est cette vidéo de
trop mais c'est une situation qui est
permanente
bien évidemment que la violence scolaire
reflète la violence la violence sociale
parce qu'il ya une concentration aussi
des problèmes et de la misère parce que
les classes supérieures mettre leurs
enfants dans le privé on a une hausse
absolument ahurissant que supérieur n'en
prenons pas que supérieur mais ils
suivent supérieur étant déjà les enfants
d
des profs mais il m'a beaucoup de profs
qui travaillent dans le public qui
mettent leurs enfants dans le privé ce
qui montre l'état de déliquescence
générale du la chose alors et bien
évidemment l'un des problèmes
un des premiers problème c'est le manque
de moyens donc ces manques de république
banque d'état il n'y a pas assez moyen
dans les écoles ya trop d'élèves par
classe c'est trop les parfois les les
communautés de primo arrivants sont trop
concentrés ils sont pas assez dispersées
à la population pour s'intégrer plus
facilement les professeurs sont très mal
payés on nous sentons nous chante
toujours le modèle allemand mais un
professeur en collège l'allemand et
voyez donc il a deux fois plus de
commandes est dans un monde d'argent et
des deux fois plus de valoriser est donc
respectée parce que le respect va aussi
avec l'argent et quand vous avez des
enseignants qui sont payés à 1300 alors
vous verrez ça messieurs pas ce que je
vais vous le dire pour vous la
féminisation de mais c'est pas ce qu'on
va faire sens et ça ça et ça peut être
considéré comme une soucoupe les prêts à
côté de la plaque de poids du tonneau
les professeurs qui me terrorise huile +
moi c'était la cause était en fait les
gens supportent encore le traumatisme
mais ce qui est très inquiétant c'est
l'état du débat là quand j'ai regardé
écouté monsieur blanc terre je me suis
souvenu
j'ai noté rapidement mais s'est
récemment c'est la série qui se passe à
baltimore
mais c'était avant il ya très longtemps
à 35 ans les films comme boyz'n the hood
où le film choc aux états unis où
michelle pfeiffer jeune prof d'anglais
arriver dans une école en fait ce qui
nous arrive c'est ce qui arrivé à
l'école aux états unis et c'est le même
processus destruction de l'école d'un
financement généralisée correct avec une
formation des enseignants payés et une
relégation d'une partie de l'école
publique dans une garderie ultra
violente où sont apparus tous ces débats
où débutent les couteaux puis les armes
puisque on met des policiers et
maintenant trump est arrivé c'est en
fait c'est à chaque fois de plus en plus
tu remets arrivé au final où maintenant
il bu sa solution s'est pas enlevé les
armes s'est armé les profs et les de
leur donner des cours non mais
d'entraînement au tir 7 des français
mg c'est là qu'on ira en fait et donc le
faut absolument revaloriser les profs
recrutés
il y avait cette magnifique système qui
était détruit d'ailleurs
début des années 80 je sais pas c'est
pas spécialement un truc de droite mais
les écoles normales
comment trouver les jeunes qui étaient
bons qu'ils recevaient des bourses y
compris dans les milieux les plus
défavorisés qui faisait l'école normale
pour les meilleurs physique faisait
l'école normale supérieure et c'est ce
qui fait que on a encore ce vivier de
chercheurs qui est rapporté la
population française fait fait qu'on a
encore des prix nobel et de grands
mathématiciens et physiciens et c'est
dommage de on a encore je pense
qu'encore 5 10 ans après c'est fini tu
es hall on sera content mais il faut
restaurer des termes peu désuet qui ont
la discipline la sanction le respect de
l'autre oui sa caution à la déconne pas
complètement alors c'est aussi apprendre
à respecter la dignité des autres juste
pour répondre à votre question sur
l'armée effectivement j'étais le jeu des
lieutenants et je vais encore d appeler
c'était la fin du service militaire donc
mais 25 % d'analphabètes fonctionnel et
ben on s'est retrouvé dans les classes
avec des jeunes qui avaient une habitude
spéciale voilà ils sont tombés sur les
ajustements des lieutenants et qu'ils
auront 10 coup de jeune homme
si j'avais si j'avais été super
intelligent j'aurais pas été alarmé
c'est adjudant qui répondait donc
l'exercice tu vas le faire et puis on va
rester jusqu'à minuit et puis tu auras
pas de perm
et puis en plus la marche code de 12 km
demain c'est moi qu'ils organisent donc
t'as intérêt à finir l'exercice a en
fait trois semaines incroyables
évolution positive et j'ai encore pris
sur les tarifs unitaires alors oui bien
sûr d'assurer le service national
composante militaire diverses mais on
l'abordera un jour d'un point de vue
auquel d'autres enseignants je pense
qu'ils ont besoin de se sentir soutenu
en fait ça aussi je dis ça ressort dans
son 2 et surtout très bien non soutenue
par par la politique générale message
envoyé quoi là relativement laxiste et
ce sur ce qu'on a dit sur le net que
c'est pas sûr que la somme à noter que
le glissement à sortir du lot sur ce
plan là alors les réactions de nos
internautes déjà la question du jour
composée sur lefigaro.fr le gouvernement
at il pris la mesure de l'augmentation
dès violences à l'école
et bien vous êtes c'est donc la question
posée sur le site 0 91% à dire que non
le gouvernement n'a pas pris la mesure
et les réactions sont généralement dans
le sens
effectivement d'un manque de soutien les
profs sont très seuls nous dit olympe
mcgraw nitot l'épreuve des violences
scolaires change énormément suivant
l'établissement
à mon avis c'est à chaque établissement
concerné par des faits de violence
d'évaluer ses besoins
la date d'établissement n'ont pas
vraiment de pouvoir pour adapter pour
oui mais pour parer autorité sur les
professeurs un réel donc on parlait du
taux de dépression et de suicide et
elodie la misère n'a rien à voir elle ne
justifie pas la violence
on passe enfin à notre dernier thème ça
concerne donc les handicapés avec ce
droit de vote et le droit de se marier
sans intervention d'un juge c'est les
deux mesures qui ont été annoncées ce
matin à l'issue d'un comité
interministériel sur le sujet alors est
ce vraiment les mesures les plus
urgentes à prendre
on en parle elles sont hautement
symbolique assure de son côté la
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées
sophie cluzel elle était ce matin sur
rmc trois cent mille personnes qui sont
des majeurs protégés sous tutelle pour
sont privés de leur droit de vote par
décision d'un juge ça doit cesser
la citoyenneté passe d'abord par
justement ce droit de vote qui est
inaliénable et qui est inconditionnel à
la citoyenneté de la personne et c'est
ce que nous voulons changer
on a assez peu de temps pour avoir des
sujets donc je vous demanderai à chacun
des trajets bref mes bonnes ou mauvaises
mesures un peu bonne mesure c'est une
mesure qui à terme être très très longue
date des associations que 13,1
emblématique de la dignité s'arrête pas
du tout où les problèmes de chômage
notamment des handicapés c'est au
chômage double
ils s'arrêtent pas les problèmes à
l'école et le manque de place mais
fallait d'abaissement mais il fallait le
faire
gentil une civilisation se mesure avec
la x qu'elle fait avec les plus fragiles
et bien sûr que c'est inadmissible qui
n'équipe pas moins de voix que c'est une
bonne chose qu'il le fasse
et d'ailleurs ça permettra de faire en
sorte que ces handicapés vote et pose la
question en tant que citoyen ou députés
en marche pourquoi ils ont refusé de
voter les augmentations pour des choses
très concrètes comme ceux qui
accompagnent les enfants handicapés dans
les écoles qui là aussi sont souvent des
femmes extrêmement mal payés avec 600
700 euros des emplois précaires et alors
c'est peut-être plus important mais le
vote parce que nous sommes dans une
démocratie est important les droits des
citoyens de tous les citoyens sont
importants à défendre mais aussi très
concrètement que leur vie soit une soit
meilleur ternat je serai un peu plus
mesuré puisque ils seront parle dans
handicapés mentaux ça sent le gros lot
d'accord il n'y a pas que les autres oui
il ya ce sont des personnes âgées qui
ont perdu 300000 personnes sous tutelle
dont une bonne part de personnes
handicapées d'accord mais si une
personne est mise sous tutelle c'est
qu'elle a perdu une partie de son dif sa
capacité du gouvernement ces cinq ans
pour juger de celle de sa propre vie de
la gestion de son compte bancaire etc
donc est elle pour autant capable de
juger de
voilà du bon représentant pour la
société de demain
je n'en suis pas sûr je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que c'est une mesure un peu
démago je lui dois soigner pourvoir en
appel d'une décision du juge des
tutelles pourquoi pas les bébés moi je
fais trois raisons ils ont ils sont
irresponsables pénalement
donc on ne peut pas à la fois ça me
paraît difficile moi ben c'est oui c'est
compliqué enfin je vois là pour eux
continuer dans ce que vous dites il ya
philippe croizon qui est alors je sais
pas s'il est très représentatif des
handicapés peut-être moins de zèle mais
c'est un fait une personnalité qui est
lui même
kadri amputés qui dit ce matin chez nos
confrères du parisien donnait droit de
vote
et ensuite comment pourront-elles les
personnes handicapées se faire leur
propre opinion devant un débat politique
à la télévision
ils s'interrogent sur les risques de
manipulation à cela sophie cluzel qui
répondent devant l'argument disant c'est
aussi ça qu'on disait pour refuser le
droit de vote aux femmes en israël sont
influençables va pouvoir
ouais là mais moi ce qui me paraît plein
il est aussi handicapé monsois on a la
coupe la capacité entière et à ce moment
là effectivement le droit de vote fait
partie de cette capacité entière et à ce
moment là vous répondait aussi
pénalement de vos actes si vous pouvez
parler ya quelque chose qui me bon qui
vous paraît pas tout à fait même si
évidemment devant calais très qu'ils
veulent mais bon quelque chose quelques
râleurs déjà sur la question la question
là on l'avait formulé ainsi pour les
personnes handicapées sous tutelle
l'accès au droit de vote est elle une
priorité
vous êtes 51% a estimé que non ce n'est
pas une priorité
un internaute nous dit par exemple le
problème c'est qu'en cas de handicap
mental grave c'est l'accompagnement qui
doit voter selon ses idées et 6 ch
il faut être en pleine possession de ses
moyens intellectuels pour être citoyen
et nicole qui dit je suis d'accord avec
bernard de la villardière c'est très
démagogique terminera sur ce point merci
beaucoup à tous les cas merci à jérémy
pompe dieu qui nous a répercuté vos
questions et un grand merci aussi à
charlotte darche à elisabeth pierre jean
et marie laëtitia bonavita qui ont
préparé cette émission avec
vous avez rendez vous demain pour un
nouveau point de vue
[Musique]